>>Eric: Good afternoon, everyone. It's my
pleasure to introduce to you Dean Karlan and
Jacob Appel of Innovations for Poverty Action.
Dean is the president and the founder by IPA.
Their group is doing very impressive work
in measuring the effectiveness of aid dollars
and using that knowledge to figure out how
to design aid programs that have really good
bang for the buck. Currently in the aid world,
a lot of aid programs are evaluated on their
effectiveness by figuring out, "Well, we had
$5 million. Did we spend it all? Yes. Great!
We're effective." But you don't really know.
Did you get $5 million worth of aid for that
or, in fact, did you do more harm than good
with that? Dean and Jacob have written a book
called 'More Than Good Intentions.' They talk
about what goes into designing their aid experiments
and some of the surprisingly small differences
and some of the very little things that one
can do to make aid more effective and to get
a lot more aid for a lot fewer dollars. Please
welcome Dean Karlan and Jacob Appel.
[applause]
>>Dean Karlan: Hi, everyone. It's great to
be here. Thanks a lot for for coming and thanks,
Eric, for putting this on and hosting. So,
there's a few different themes to I want to
talk about that are related but might sound
very different. The first theme that I want
to talk about is exactly what Eric said. Which
is, how do we... what are we doing to take
data to help figure out what really works
and what does not? What is... what is this
journey about? What is it that we're doing
differently than what's been done before?
The second thing I want to talk about us how
we're thinking about designing some of the
programs and the interventions that we're
looking into. And specifically a lot of the
work we're doing uses lessons from behavioral
economics, but not always behavioral. Sometimes
it's just plain vanilla economics. This is
one of the themes in the book, too, and we
go back and forth between behavioral and more
traditional economics, mixing the two up.
And to understand, in a given situation what's
the what's the right way of thinking about
how to solve a particular problem.
The third theme that we'll talk about, and
Jake will come up and speak about as well,
has to do with how do we sift through of all
this information that's out there? This is
something near and dear to all of us here
at Google, obviously, is, you know, tons and
tons of information can come flooding to us
about different charities and doing different
work. How do we sift through that to figure
out what actually... what actually works?
So sometimes I think it helps to be a little
bit personal for a moment and let me tell
you about how I got into doing this. In 1992,
I just finished two years of investment banking
and I moved to El Salvador. I was heading,
from there I was going to go back to get an
MBA, probably go work in a hedge fund or something
of that nature. And I took a detour, a detour
for a year to work for an organization that
-- this is pre-Internet days -- that I had
seen a brochure about. And it seemed very
appealing to me and very attractive. It really
hit my... It both hit my heart and my mind.
But not my mind in a data sense, my mind in
the sense that the theory of what they're
doing me sense to me. And what they were doing
was microcredit.
Now what's the canonical microcredit story?
The canonical microcredit story says we're
going to take money and we're going to lend
it out to women who have enterprising ideas,
and are entrepreneurial, are a high-energy,
are really motivated to do something about
the problem they're facing in their life -- the
poverty that they're stricken with. And they're
doing this in order to fight for the family,
for their children, to improve the health
and education of their children. It's a very
inspiring story that we've heard probably
many... I'm guessing many people in the room
have heard this story told this way. You know,
here was I ... I was coming from a banking
background and this seemed perfect. Right?
In banking, I had some computer backgrounds.
So I went down and I was developing software
systems for managing their portfolios.
The thing that struck me the most was the
conversations at night. So talking with people
who were working with this group. And a lot
of people in this group -- very smart people
-- but not using any sort of data to help
guide what they were doing. And I remember
asking, "What is the impact of this? What
do we think is happening with the impact here?"
The first thing that struck me when I moved
to El Salvador was what the interest rate
was. Right? So in this brochure that I saw
that inspired me to move to El Salvador to
do this there was no mention of the interest
rate. And if you'd asked me, I would have
said, "Well, you know, I understand the principle
here is kind of sustainable development. There
has to be some revenue, so there's probably
going to be some nominal interest rate fee
of 5%, 10%. It turns out it was 72% a year
-- the interest rate. And, you know my first
reaction was ... I was kind of disheartened.
I remember the feeling of my heart sinking
and thinking "What's going on here?"
Now, that sounds bad, but, you know, then
we sat down and we talked with some of the
clients who were engaging this program, and
we asked them the types of things that we
saw them doing and how they were maybe doing
something differently as getting access to
loans. It wasn't actually that hard to come
up with returns that high. Returns that high
for a microenterprise could actually be reasonably
that high. So that's not actually enough to
say ... just looking at that interest rate
is by no means enough to say, "Oh, this is
a bad idea."
Now, when we asked the organization, "What
is your impact?", this is what they gave us.
They gave us a study that asked their existing
clients who had been with them for a couple
years, "Are you eating better now than you
were two years ago?" OK. And that was it.
That was the extent. And then they ... some
other questions, too. "Are you earning more
in your business?" Right? And this was the
... this was the state of what they were doing
in terms of impact measurement. They were
not doing anything different -- I have now
learned -- than anybody else in this space.
So this is not a criticism of them. This is
a statement of where the world was in terms
of measuring impact of microcredit. Now, I
had a major in political science. It didn't
take ... it didn't take a ... you know, it
didn't take training to just kind of say,
"OK, now wait a second." The world is happening
at the same time. So, did it ... is it ... can
we really say that microcredit caused these
people to be eating better and earn more money?
Or could it be the macroeconomic conditions?
Could it be just weather was good? Could it
just be that they were in an upward trajectory
anyhow because they're individuals who were
chosen because they are fighting individuals?
Inspiring individuals? Entrepreneurial individuals?
That's what the brochure said. That's who
they're lending to. And so what is it that
caused them to do better? So I remember thinking
at the time that, you know, what else could
we put into this and claim microcredit causes?
Imagine that survey also said, "Are you feeling
older now than you were two years ago?" Would
we go and then take this to the brochures
and say that microcredit causes aging? Right?
The rigor of that conclusion would have been
just as solid as the rigor of the conclusion
that they caused an increase in income. So
the point of this is that, you know, we need
to have some basis of attribution, right?
We need to know whether our aid is doing something.
And we need to ... when we went in and asked
that question, what we really are asking is,
"How have the lives of the people in a program
changed compared to how their lives would
have changed had this program not existed?"
And to do that second part of that question,
you have to do something more than just follow
your clients over time and see what types
of changes occur in their life. And this is
the heart of what we're doing as an organization,
and, you know, as my research as a professor
at Yale is very much dedicated to setting
up experimental processes so that we can measure
what is the actual impact of a particular
type idea.
Now, in [pause] in the case of microcredit,
we have now done rigorous impact evaluations
of microcredit. We've done three from researchers
in our group, and the results that we get
from this are striking. And the reaction is
actually much more striking, I find. So, prior
to the research we'd been doing on microcredit,
the conventional wisdom and the rhetoric around
microcredit said it was almost like it was
the panacea to solve poverty. It's the silver
bullet. It's going to increase income, increase
health, increase education, increase female
empowerment in the household. The list goes
on. And in ... What we are finding with the
studies is that there were important benefits
that were accrued to the families who received
access to microcredit compared to a randomly
assigned control group that did not get access
to the microcredit. But we did not find that
these things solved poverty by any means.
Now, the pendulum has swung and it's a frustrating
thing to see as a researcher when your research
gets overinterpreted the wrong way, and then
people are saying that "Oh, microcredit's
bad." The results that we're finding is that
microcredit does have some benefits, but it's
really pointing out very, very poignantly
that we need to think about opportunity costs.
It's not the silver bullet. And if we're doing
microcredit, that means our money's not going
and doing something else. So what's better?
What's the right answer?
And so this is the ... this is the heart of
the first theme. What really works? Right?
And when I left El Salvador, I went back to
graduate school because this is what I saw
as the biggest gap, was this lack of rigor
of analytics in terms of understanding what
the impact was and understanding how programs
were designed. So I went back to graduate
school to get a Ph.D. in economics to study
these types of questions.
What I found when I went back to graduate
school was -- with certain exceptions like
my advisers who I was working with -- the
debate was strikingly frustrating. The debate
was answering the question "Does development
aid work?" And this is just a bad question
-- particularly if you're going to expect
a "yes" or "no." OK. First, the answer ... The
answer is, first of all, so quite reasonable:
that some aid works and some aid does not.
And how can you argue with that? But yet,
that was not the debate that we were seeing
... was this polar opposite of aid ... and
it was also this very monolithic view of poverty:
that we were just measuring poverty at the
country level and then asking whether aid
flows reduces poverty. And it was a very frustrating
set of research to try to absorb and figure
out what to do with. And the revolution which
started taking place in the mid-1990s in development
economics was to say, "Well, let's stop this
debate from the ivory tower, from these large
cross-country datasets that are ... where
the data is aggregated up to a level where
we've lost all understanding of what we're
really measuring, and let's go to the ground.
And by going to the ground, we can set up
careful tests and collect data that we actually
know what it is, know what it represents,
measure the actual changes in people's lives,
measure the counterfactual of what whould
have happened by setting up randomized trials,
and knowing what happened, what would have
happened, and measuring the actual change
in people's lives as a result of access to
various services or programs or interventions."
And this applies to government, NGO, as well
as for-profit entities. So that's the first
theme of the book. And it ... we talk a lot
about the examples of this type of ground
research in microfinance, in health, education,
etc.
The second theme of the book is about behavioral
economics, and, specifically, lessons from
behavioral economics that can help us think
about how to design better programs, and how
behavioral economics changes, sometimes, ways
that we think about things in subtle, but
really important, ways. So, one example which
stays true to the microcredit topic which
I already raised is about what we call loans.
Do we call a loan "credit" or "debt?" Right?
So the striking thing about microloans is
that we can take ... I can take the same exact
loan, the same terms, conditions, interest
rates, everything, in a developing country,
and describe it to you, and tell you the organization
to send money to where you can get a tax deduction
for supporting that loan, that creation of
that loan. And you can get a tax deduction
for this under the umbrella of a charity doing
good work. And that would be called microcredit.
In the U.S., we can take the same exact loan
and now we'll call it debt. It's the same
interest rate, same terms, same conditions.
And now what's ... what are the non-profit
organizations going to be doing around that?
They're going to be trying to figure out how
to get people to not do that. To not take
out that loan. To pay it down faster. To not
take it out in the first place. Or to pass
regulation or laws to shut it down so they
can't even have the loan if they want it;
that the lender is not allowed to make it
for them ... by passing usury laws.
OK, so there's something ... there's three
ways of thinking about that -- reconciling
those two things. One is to say, "Well, we're
wrong to be doing it overseas. Those are bad
loans for people and they're making people
worse off, and we're right about it in the
United States." A second is to say, "No, no,
no, no. We really should free markets up in
the U.S. and, yes, maybe we can help people
think about the right decision, whether they
should be borrowing or saving. But we shouldn't
be restricting the market. We should be letting
it happen just the same way we do overseas."
A third is to say that I'm being loose with
my analogy and that the two are ... other
things are different. And I'll admit that
I'm being a little bit loose, but not so loose
as to be ... I don't think I'm wrong. There
is an overlap in these two worlds. You know,
there are some loans in the U.S. that you
wouldn't see overseas and vice-versa, that
are supported. Now, but that's just an example
of word choice making such a powerful difference
in how we perceive something. And this is
true in a lot of spaces. When we want to ... when
we want to figure out how to sell charity,
or when we want to sell goods in developing
countries, we need to think about that last
mile. How would you actually get products
into the hands of individuals? Is it as good
as just create the intervention and then with
that everybody will use it? Or do you actually
have to think about how to sell it? Right?
In the same way that that word -- credit or
debt -- has a very different meaning to us.
Credit is good. We earn credit. We don't earn
debt. Right? Debt is bad. That's something
we owe. We're indebted to people or indebted
to firms. So that very ... that simple word
choice, which has the same actual meaning
in terms of economics, you know, puts a very
different mindset to us when we think about
whether we like it or not, whether it's a
good or bad thing, whether we should encourage
people or not.
One of the other themes in the book -- one
of the other behavioral examples in the book
-- is one about temptation and how is it that
we deal with temptation in life. We all have
different things that tempt us. How do we
go about figuring out how to resist temptation
and are there ways of offering people products
and services that help people resist temptation
better? So that they can achieve the things
they want to achieve. And the fun thing about
this one is that this is a universal thing,
right? It's not to say that it's universal
what tempts us, obviously. I have different
temptations than everybody else in this room,
no doubt. Everybody's unique in what it is.
And, you know, maybe there's someone on this
planet who has no temptations, but I haven't
met that person yet. So, for me, you know,
I love peanut M&Ms, and, you know, if I could
make it so that the peanut M&M company would
only sell them to me at a price of $100 a
bag, I would actually be really happy. I'd
like that. I would eat many fewer peanut M&Ms.
Now, you know, understanding how people deal
with temptation solves a few problems all
at once. And this is kind of the fun part
of thinking through the theory of how people
make decisions. We look at a project in the
book in Kenya in which we use an understanding
of temptation and how people manage their
money to help farmers invest more fertilizer
to increase yield in their farm. And it's
the same principle that we go to the Philippines
and we look at a program that we tested that
helped people stop smoking. And it's the same
type of thinking that takes us back to America
to a website that I started called "stickK"
-- stickK.com -- which one of my co-founders,
Ian Ayres, spoke here at Google, I think about
two years ago, and talked about this as well.
And it's a website that we started in the
United States that can help people lose weight,
stop smoking, or achieve more success at work,
or at home, etc. So what's the underlying
prinicple is a committment contract. And it's
... the basic idea is "How do you make your
vices more expensive? How can I make it so
that peanut M&Ms cost me more money?" So an
example of what I did last night at dinner
tells you exactly how this type of thing can
work. So last night at dinner, I know if I
... my sweet spot when eating a nice meal
is to have wine and no dessert. OK, so if
I can plan ahead and achieve exactly what
I want to do, I will have wine and no dessert.
I do know myself well enough, unfortunately,
that after I've had wine, dessert looks much
better. OK? So after I've had my wine, if
I then am asked if I want dessert, a lot of
times I'll end up saying "yes" to the dessert.
Right? So if I have to rank my preferences,
my first choice is wine, no dessert. My second
choice is neither. And my third choice is
both. That's me speaking now about my dinner
tonight. But I know that if I'm actually eating
dinner, that the wine plus dessert will sneak
its way to the top, and that'll end up being
what I do. So, how do I ... how do I solve
this? How can I get it so that wine and no
dessert ends up being what I actually do?
So what I did last night ... I was exactly
in this setting and I can do it again because
I'm here with two people who I'm going to
be having dinner with tonight, and so I will
say the same thing to you now. So if you see
me eating dessert tonight at dinner, I owe
you each $1000. OK, so now I can eat, drink
my wine and feel confident that I'm not going
to order dessert for $2012.95. Right? $12.95
I will. $2012.95? No, not going to happen.
OK, so now that's a problem solved. So I just
wrote a very simple commitment contract. Um,
technically, I probably, like, need to pay
them a $1 ... they need to pay me $1 for it
or something like that to make it legally
binding. But it's socially binding 'cause
I will definitely hear the wrath from them
if I don't pay up and eat dessert. And so
that's, that's an example of how we're thinking
about ways to help people modify behavior
towards their own goals, towards things that
they preemptively said they want to do. And
that's how the stickK website works. You can
go online. You write a contract. You say,
"I'm going to lose weight, stop smoking."
One of my favorite contracts was someone who
said, "I'm going to speak more slowly to foreigners
in New York City. I'm not going to date any
more losers." And named one of their friends
as a referee who could hold them accountable.
So [sips water] [pause] And then you put money
or social shame at stake. A lot of people
just put their emails of friends and family
who then are informed of whether they succeed
or failed. And that might work better for
some people than financial stakes. If you
put financial stakes, the single most popular
option is the George Bush Presidential Library.
So the idea being that the money gets zapped
away to something that they hate. Now we're
not ... we're agnostic. We're not taking sides,
obviously, on a political issue. So we give
people both. That just tells you something
about who happens to be using the site more.
But we give the Bill Clinton and the George
Bush Presidential Library. And we take five
other hot political issues and we give people
both sides. And these are called the anti-charities.
So you pledge your money to the thing you
hate. For people from England or U.K. Premiere
League fans, you can also choose major teams,
Man U, Arsenal, Chelsea. And again, you choose
the team you hate and your money will go off
to that club. So this is a very simple commitment
device where you just raised the price. You
said what you're going to do. And you put
money at stake. And then, if you fail, your
money goes away. And it's a very simple way
of raising the price of vice or you can also
think of it as lowering the price of virtue.
It's the same ... it's the same basic formula.
OK. So that's ... That was theme two. I now
want to invite Jake Appel to come on up, who
is going to talk about the third theme in
the book. And then I will wrap up and also
plant some ideas with you on some things we
want to be doing in the future.
[pause]
>>Jacob Appel: Thanks. [pause] So, um, as
Dean said, I want to talk a little bit more
about why this book. So Dean, Dean told you
a little bit about what is in this book, and
I want to say why we saw fit to write it.
So, that sort of brings the focus back to
us here as, as donors, as practitioners, people
who are engaged with the issues of poverty
and poverty alleviation, and, and what's the
sort of situation that we face. Well, a lot
of us face a flood of information from charities
and from development organizations to, to
just try to grab our attention and to eventually
try to grab our money. And the, the problem
here is that the information calling out to
us is not always the right information. It's
not, it's not what tells us about which programs
are going to be the most effective, which
are going to create the biggest change in
the world per dollar. More often it, it goes
back to the theme Dean talked about, which
is behavioral. So, charities are quite savvy.
They know how to pull at our heartstrings.
They know how to show us photographs of people
who are really suffering, fly-bitten babies.
They know how to sell us sponsor-a-child programs,
where you can get a -- you can make a personal
connection with a person that you help. These
kinds of strategies are really powerful. They,
they tug at our heartstrings and they, they
really engage us on a personal level. And
in a sense, that's great. It's good to be
engaged anyhow, but, but it's much better
to be engaged and be thinking proactively
about what am I supporting? Where's my money
going? At least we think so. So, [pause] so
the ways that charities can, can attract our
attention is by making it either more compelling
or just easier to give. So, the one side is
these kind of personal stories and the compelling
photographs that really arouse our sympathies.
Another way is by breaking down the barriers
to giving. So that's, that's things like in
the checkout at Whole Foods, you can give
a dollar to the Whole Planet Foundation -- so
microcredit fund -- and when you tack on $1
to a $100 grocery bill, "Surprise, surprise!"
it doesn't hurt so much. It's very easy to
give on the margin when you're already spending
a bunch of money. Along similar lines is the
donate-by-text campaigns that we saw particularly
after the earthquake in Haiti. So, there's
a very funny kind of anecdote to come out
of that which, which illustrates a basic point.
And that's when it's too easy to give, sometimes
we make mistakes. We just, we give without
thinking. Generally it's not so bad to make
a mistake and have it be charitable, but,
but it's a mistake nonetheless. So, I want
to just read this anecdote -- which we talk
about in the book -- which describes one of
these mistakes. And it's kind of funny. So
this is from, from Facebook. So.
[reading] "Giving by text message takes a
few seconds and is utterly gratifying. You
type in Haiti, press send, get an instant
response thanking you for your generosity.
You hardly have time to think of the phone
bill coming at the end of the month. And when
it does arrive, your $10 is easier to part
with because it's tacked on to the cost of
phone service, a cost you're already prepared
to bear. Unless, that is, you are Cara. The
following was pulled from a real Facebook
page. Cara's profile said, 'I've texted Haiti
to 90999 over 200 times, that's over $2000
donated to Haiti relief efforts. Join me.'
So she's excited. Then, underneath the status
update were some comments from her friends.
And her friend, Noah, said, 'Your parents
might not like your cell phone bill this month.'
Cara said, 'It's not my money. Ha! Wait a
second. This doesn't get added to the phone
bill, does it? I thought it was just a free
thing.' And her other friend says, 'Cara,
shoot, no. Every text is $10.' 'Oh, wow. Are
you sure? This could be very bad for me.'
Then he says, 'Yeah, I saw it on the football
game. They bill it to your cell phone bill.'
Another friend chimed in, 'Yeah, every text
is 10 bucks. It said so when the Health and
Human Services lady came on and told people
about it on Colbert Report. Uh, maybe you
should ask for people to help you pay your
phone bill?' And Cara said, 'Well, thanks
for letting me know. Ha, ha. Haiti must love
me.' [audience chuckles]
So, so that's kind of the, the point, right?
It can be too easy to give and Cara's $2000
mistake is not a tragedy in the, in the big
picture of the world. It's not a bad thing
to give $2000, even of her parents' money,
even by accident. But, but optimally, we could
do better, right? We could, we could as donors
be a little bit more critical and we could
ask proactively, "Which things do I want to
support?" and, and ideally we could make that
decision on the basis of impacts. So, I'd
like to use my dollars to make the most, the
biggest possible difference in the world on
some set of outcomes that I care about. And,
and so we should look to the evidence of which
programs achieve those goals most effectively.
And, and so this book is -- we hope -- helps
people to do exactly that. So the, the sort
of first, most basic goal is to get people
thinking more critically, and more proactively,
and asking questions. And then we close the
book, the sort of last chapter is a little
bit of a cheat sheet where we, we name a few
ideas that we're particularly excited about
which have sort of come out through this process
of evaluation. And they're looking — some
of them are more proven than others, but,
in general, evidence shows them to be quite
effective. So, one caveat there is that the
book is printed and the ink is dry, but research
is always on-going. So, the ideas we talk
about there mirror an initiative at IPA called
'The Proven Impact Initiative', where IPA
is constantly combing through current research
and consolidating it into recommendations
of ideas, particular approaches, that are
shown to be especially effective achieving
particular outcomes. So, so that's something
to keep track of, too. So that's a little
more about the why of this book, and now Dean
will tie it up.
[pause]
>>Dean Karlan: Thanks. Thanks, Jake. So, [pause]
so I want to just tie it up by telling you
a little bit more on what we're doing, on
what Jake just said. So, Innovations for Poverty
Action is a non-profit that I started in 2002.
And we're now have projects in 46 countries
and almost 500 employees. About 250 employees
that are U.S. or European on U.S. payroll,
and about half of our staff are permanent
staff, local, local nationals helping to manage
our projects overseas. We've grown really
rapidly. And part of the reason for that is
-- there's two reasons why we started the
pro -- started this in the first place. And
one of the reasons for our growth, that our
rapid growth, is the first of these reasons.
The first was doing this field work was not
what we learned to do when we were in graduate
school. That's the reality. The reality is
that we learn in graduate school about theory,
we learn about data analysis, and we do not
learn how to manage a team of surveyors and
we do not learn survey design, and we do not
learn -- well, maybe a little survey design
-- but we do not learn some of the day-to-day
management that needs to go into actually
going and collecting this field work, or,
in many cases, if we're actually working on
an intervention we're working with some group
and helping them think through what the actual
product is that they're testing. And we're
getting involved in that space. And this is
not our normal way of doing things in academia.
And one of the things that I recognized when
I finished graduate school is that we needed
an entity that didn't just churn, in and out,
undergrads and grad students for one year.
That we needed an entity with a life, that
had its own internal capacity, its own internal
learning, that stayed with people. And so
that was one of the reasons for creating Innovations
for Poverty Action. And what we found very
quickly was once we created it, and people
came. I mean, the researchers really saw the
value of this because if they're a researcher
and did not have that staff, and said all
of a sudden "I want to do a project in Ghana.
Can you help me?" And we said, "Yes." And
then we helped them. And then we saw, and
then they see that they can take their skill
set as professors, and then there's this field
arm that can really go and execute very well
the field, the field research. It was a great
marriage. And we grew without really trying,
merely by doing what we were doing and becoming
an organization that groups, that researchers
kept coming to us and saying, "Can you help?
Can you help? Can you help?" And, similarly,
foundations kept coming ... and foundations
and saying, "Wow. We saw this research and
we want to do more of it."
So we got really good at the knowledge creation
side, in terms of being a conduit for the
researchers who wanted to do research, the
foundations that wanted answers to questions.
The ... What do you do with all that information,
though? That was one of the other key "ahas"
and inspiring moments for starting Innovations
for Poverty Action was recognizing that if
I just respond to my academic incentives and
other researchers just respond to their academic
incentives, we're not really gonna make the
impact on the world that we want to make,
that for many of us is what inspired us to
do this type of work. And for that we needed
an organization that is committed to a couple
different things. One is to working with,
with donors and with organizations to get
that information into the right hands. The
information overload problem that Jake mentioned
with Cara and the things being shouted at
us. This is about donors, but it's also about
the people who work for OxFam, work for CARE.
How do they sift through it all to figure
out what's really gonna work and what they
should be doing? The problem is on, on many
levels. And so that's where the, the information
dissemination is so important for us as an
organization to work. And with donors -- small
and medium and as well as large. But the large
donors, that's a conversation that as professors
we're often engaged in anyhow, conversations
with the World Bank and Gates Foundation and
groups like that. But we're not engaged as
a professor with conversations with people
who are, are in running small, medium family-sized
foundations or even smaller retail type, type
audience. So it's that, that communication
work and that outreach to organizations that's
so important to what we're doing now, and,
and one of the main areas that we're pushing
to grow as an, as an organization.
Now, um. So I want to close with giving you
three ideas. This is a ... I talked with a
couple of people who, who, who told me that
it's really important when talking with people
at Google to not just talk and say, "Woohoo,
look at what we -- Look at this book. And
this is what we found," but to try to throw
out some ideas to the, to the audience to
say that here's an example of, of very proactive
things that, that we're looking for help to
do to see if there's anybody that's interested
in help.
So, let me give you one. So one is: what's
striking to us is ... we are, we're an organization
that's -- we're dead without data. And, and
by dead without data I also mean we're dead
without a good way of collecting data. When
I first started doing survey work, it was
pen and paper. And that was how we did it.
We went out and we printed paper, you know.
We'd go out and collect it and then someone
sat there and did data input and that's how
we did it. We're now seeing in the world,
there's a lot of different kinds of bootstrap
things that are going on in a lot of different
platforms that are incomplete, but that are
trying to solve this data collection problem
of having surveyors go out in the field and,
and gather data that gets then fed back to
us. But there's not a really good platform
for doing this that really cuts across all
of the various needs and, and types of circumstances
that we find ourselves in. And we're not unique
in this. There's other groups that value this,
too. This is not just a research tool. There's
a lot of organizations that need this type
of data for their own internal monitoring
and accountability. And, and, and, so how
is that ... what's the right platform for
that? And so we, we've grappled with a few
pieces of software that are out there, but
nothing ever kind of fits the, fits the, fits
the, the total answer.
A second thing that is, that, that is related
to, to what I was talking about, to -- earlier
about opportunity costs. One of the things
that's striking to me is how many people I,
I talk to that say that they have intentions
for giving to charity, that don't. But then
when you look at what they actually do, they
don't quite live up to what they said they're
going to do. And this is not much different
than the temptation story I was talking about
earlier. You say you're going to do some things.
Then you get tempted away by other things.
And then you look at your bank account. You're
making your charitable donation and you don't
have as much in that bank account as you thought
you were going to have. And so you end up
making less that was originally intended.
How, how do we go about making that, that
link more, more salient between consumption
and, and charity? So one -- there's an example
from my -- that I experienced that I think
can -- tells a lot about this. So I was in,
I was in Peru. And I have a jacket that I
bought in Peru about 8 years ago that's made
of alpaca wool. And it has holes in it now.
And so I'm back in Peru for the first time
in a while and I'm thinking, "Oh, this would
be nice to go get a new jacket 'cause I'm
sick and tired of walking down the street
and having someone chase me down saying, 'Sir,
your wallet. You dropped your wallet.' 'Cause
there's too many holes in my pocket. And what's
embarrassing, that's happened more than once.
You'd think that once would be enough. But,
no, right? But, regardless. So I'm there and
I'm thinking, you know, maybe I should go
ahead and get another jacket. So I go into
a store which is where I think I bought it
8 years ago, and the jacket was $300. Now
that's a bit more than I would typically spend
on a jacket. I'm not the type of person who
spends money on clothing. And I'm -- So I'm
first thinking that maybe this wasn't the
store. Maybe I just came into the store, and
bought it somewhere else. And so I'm shopping
around and I'm not finding a jacket that I
like that's for, that's made of alpaca that's
less than $300. And then I thought to myself,
"Do I really need this jacket?" I have a jacket.
It wasn't the alpaca one. I had another one
that was just a simple North Face jacket that
I like. Do I really need this second jacket?
And then I thought to myself, "Well, what's
the opportunity cost? What, what else would
I do with $300? What else could $300 do?"
Well, a simple trade-off is 60 bed nets. Right?
On average will 60 bed nets save a child's
life? I don't know the exact math, but let's
say, roughly, yes. So I thought to myself,
"OK. Great.That's a better choice." It is
a clear choice. I can't spend the $300 on
both. It's not the ... we're not talking the
Kennedy Silver Magic bullet here that can
go through both things. Right? So it's either-or.
So I made the choice on the bed nets. Did
I send the money off to the bed net place
when I got home? No. Haven't done it yet.
Not explicitly.
So, why not? What if I was able to have a
platform at that very moment that I could
just send an email, log in to the website,
where I make that transfer salient. I make
that mental account very clear that I am foregoing
this item specifically in order to support
a particular cause. And now I'm holding myself
accountable by having this, this mental accounting
process that is now on this platform and I
can ... You can imagine many ways of. of feeding
information into it. You can imagine having
social networks that, that agree on common
consumption goods to give up. Maybe it's the
daily latté that when you add it up for the
entire year you go, "My gosh. Really? I'm
spending $2000 a year on lattés?" You know,
maybe that's something I could give up and
$2000 can do something else. So, so the tool
can do a lot to help people see the salience
of what they're giving up. And, and this might
inspire more giving. And for some maybe it
wouldn't. But for those who want to aspire
to be more charitable in their trade-offs,
it would be a tool for helping them see and
make that sali-, make that trade-off very
salient. So there's, there's an analogy that
comes from Peter Singer, who's a philosopher
at Princeton, that tells a lot, that makes
this analogy exactly, perfectly. The analogy
is you're walking down the street and there's
a child drowning in a lake. And you're on
your way to a meeting. And if you jump in
that lake to save that child, you're going
to miss that meeting. And let's say, for simplicity,
that meeting is going to earn you $300. So
you have a trade-off right now. $300 or the
child. Most people would say that there's
an ethical obligation for, certainly for people
who are of modest capabilities financially,
to forego the $300 and save that child's life.
OK. So, right now in Africa the same logic
could apply. Go ... I can give you the names
of 20 different organizations that are immunizing
children, or passing out bed nets. $300. Child's
life. It's the same exact trade-off. There
is one key difference. And this goes back
to the first theme of this entire, the entire
book. So a lot of people responded and I'm
willing to be that a lot of people right in
this room are saying to me, "No, no, no, Dean.
You're wrong. It's not the same. You told
me that I can save that child. And I know
how to swim and so I will save that child.
But how do I know the $300 is gonna save the
child in Africa? How do I really know that?"
Right? And that's one of the reasons for doing
this type of data work, this type of evaluation.
Is to remove some, at least some, of that
uncertainty so that you know that $300 can
actually make a difference, and here's how
to do it. And that's one of the motivations
for doing it. And also what the other message
from that analogy is about the salience of
what we're giving up. And, and the key is:
how can we create an app or a tool to help
people think more concretely about the trace,
the choices they make in life, so that they
can adhere to the value system that they say
they have? And how can we make the data actually
help people fit the values that they claim
to have and want to have? So that's, that's
something that I'm very excited about. And
if there's people here interested in doing
that, please, by all means, let me, let me
know.
There's one other twist to that lake analogy,
just to, just to fill the loop in. So if you
ever want to talk about that, it's-- the other
thing to do is to, to make it so that you
can't swim. OK. But there's a lifesaver on
the other side of the lake. And then ask yourself,
"Do you have an ethical obligation to miss
that meeting? To go all the way to the other
side of the lake? Find that lifesaver? Throw
it into the lake and hope you hit the child?"
Well, not hit them on the head, hopefully,
and pass them out. But hit them -- get it
near the child. Right? So now, what have I
done? I've made both of them a, a, an uncertain
event. You may save the child with the lifesaver.
You may save the child in Africa. Don't know
about either. Right. So that, that's another
way of changing that analogy to kind of wreak
havoc with, with why people answer them differently.
OK. The third thing -- just to let you know
-- in terms of how IPA is structured. Right.
So we don't, we do a lot of projects where
an organization comes to us and says, "Please
tell us if we're, if this works. We'd like
to see an evaluation." And a donor comes to
us and says, "We want to know if that works.
We're supporting that. And we want to know
whether we should support more of it. And
so please do an evaluation of the pilot so
that we can whether we should scale it up."
And we, we like those projects. But the projects
that we really love, that have much bigger
impact in terms of numbers, is when we can
take a step back, working with the donors,
working with the organizations doing things
and saying, "What are the questions that you
need answering in order to crack this nut?
And now how can we set up evaluations and,
and experiments that help answer those types
of problems?" And that's when we, we have
initiatives that have pots of money -- usually
ranging from two to ten million dollars -- where
we then have an ability to take a step back
and say, "We need research that's going to
answer these five questions." And then we
open it up to researchers to propose specific
settings in which they think they can nail
one of these five questions. And then we use
this process to facilitate the funding of,
of research to answer particular questions.
So, for instance, the small-medium enterprise
market is a huge market that we see a lot
of stagnation, a lot of lack of growth. And
that's where jobs can get created. The, the
term "entrepreneur" for microcredit, in microcredit
-- to bring us back to the microcredit conversation
-- is a very sexy term to most people in America.
Certainly, I'm guessing, to everybody in this
room. It's a, it is to me. 'Entrepreneur is
exciting.' It's not ... In developing countries,
entrepreneur is synonymous with "I don't have
a job." That's a very different beast. Right?
And it's really a misplaced goal to say that
microenterprise growth, the goal of microenterprise
is to grow microenterprises into small-medium
enterprises. We want to take people with zero
employees and somehow figure out how to get
them 10, or 20, or 100 employees. That's a,
that's a diamond in the rough. But there are,
there are firms out there that are hiring
some. Not too many. And then the question
is, "What's hindering their growth?" They've
gotten over the hurdle of the zero employee
to some employees. Now, what's necessary to
get them bigger so that they can create more
jobs? That's a huge nut that we're trying
to crack. So, other ones that are in that
space are on the savings side. When we've
seen the lackluster, the positive but still
not, not super-exciting results on impact
of credit, that's focused our energy a lot
to ask, "Well, what about savings?" Savings,
you don't have the higher interest rates.
You're -- and what do we need to do to then
help people save up to things that they want
to do? And so we have an initiative that is
about savings. Similarly, there's, there's
a lot of work that we've talked about. We've
thought about having an initiative on mobile,
on mobile apps. There's a huge number of interventions
that, that we can talk about that are interesting
and exciting. But at the same time we wonder,
"OK. Is this just exciting 'cause it's kind
of cool or is it actually going to improve
welfare in a way that's important?" And so,
how can technology be used to improve people's
lives in, in rural areas of Africa or Latin
America, Asia? And again, there,it wouldn't,
we want to be able to take the approach of
rather than just finding a particular thing
and evaluating it, we want to be able to step
back and understand what are the, what are
the key, over-arching questions we have to
ask. You know, one obvious one is can the
technology alone do something? Or when do
we have to think about combining technology
with a human touch in terms of the way things
are integrated into a development program?
And so those, better understanding of how
the interaction has to take place in order
to make sure the technology's used for good
is an important question that we want to ask.
And so that's an example where we're looking
for a pot of funds that we can then work creatively
to help answer the questions that the, the
researchers, the researchers in this case,
what I mean, is the technology researchers,
and the organizations, and the donors are
looking for answers to these questions in
order to know what to, what to scale up and
what not. So, so with that, I will turn it
to Q & A. [pause]
[applause]
>> Eric: If you have questions, please come
up to the mike so that the remote sites and
the recording can get your question. [pause]
[Dean sips water.]
>>Female Audience Member #1: Thank you. It
was a really good talk. Um, my question is
regards to, well, a couple points you brought
up when you were talking about, you know,
how easy it is to give, and how -- basically,
the message I took was it's important to research
and make a good economic choice about where
you put your money and make sure that it works.
But how do you reconcile that with, basically,
government charity where I really can't choose
particularly where my money goes. It's taken
from me and it goes into some giant hole,
and policy-wise things don't change very rapidly.
If something's discovered not to work, they
can't change it very quickly, either. How
do those kind of reconcile those two viewpoints?
>>Dean Karlan: So, I mean, there is, though,
I mean, so clearly. We don't have a -- I've
heard people proposals of a taxation system
where we actually get to choose allocations.
I actually think that might be a dangerous
thing. Having said that, there, there is a
lot of work, and a lot of our researchers
are working in the developing countries. When
we work, we are working with USAID or Millenium
Challenge Corporation, which are two U.S.
government agencies, to help use this type
of evaluation to help them direct their resources
to better decisions. The Department of Education,
the Department of Labor have been doing rigorous-type,
randomized trials for a long time. Actually,
the first randomized trials in economics that
were done were in the 1960s by the U.S. government.
So I'm not saying that it's like, like everything
fits that bill, by any means. I don't want
to pass that. But I think the answer is the
same. And it's not ... But I wouldn't put
that in the hands of the, of the taxpayer.
Right? That's in the hands of, of the executive
branch of the government and the Congress
to say, "Let's take evaluation more seriously
in how we think about what we're doing. And
there are a lot of ... there are some ... a
lot of government programs which do do that.
And, obviously, there's a lot that do not.
>>Female Audience Member #1: Yeah. But I guess
my question is: From a government perspective
they get the money. Where's their incentive
to provide this proof of value to us?
>>Dean Karlan: So there is -- okay, so, there
is -- look. There's a political risk that
obviously a lot have overcome. But, you know,
nobody wants their program to appear like
a failure. So you have to, as a politician,
really promote the point that you are, you
are exercising prudence in making sure that
you choose the right thing. And look, and
look, just as a matter of fact, there are
a lot of randomized trials done on government
funding projects. So, I mean it is, just in
terms of looking at the way the world does
work, this has been overcome in a lot of situations.
And there are a lot of government funded programs
which do go through that. But by any means
I am not trying to say there's, like, enough.
I think more should. But it is the case that
there's a lot of government programs that
receive that. Millenium Challenge Corporation
is a good example of one that from the day
one of that group -- I'm not saying that everything
... that I like everything they do. But one
thing they have taken very seriously is when
we can, we want to see randomized trials done
to evaluate our aid. And that was done from
day one. And USAID is really moving in that
direction. We'll see. It's a big ship. It
needs moving. But the people, they -- that
Obama brought in at the top are really dedicated
to introducing strong evaluations to help
guide their resources. So, you know, where
there's, where there's will, there's a way.
And you, there is, there is a message that
needs to be managed. Because if the evaluations
start proving that everything failed, they
have to make sure from the political messaging
to get their, get their PR people kind of
figuring out how to deal with that problem
to make sure that the message is that, like,
"Hey. We learned it didn't work and we changed
our decision because of that. Because we're
smart and we learn." I'd like to think that's
how the world could work.
>>Female Audience Member #1: Yeah. It could.
>>Male Audience Member #1: Thanks for [inaudible].
This is really fascinating. My question to
you is related to how we as Google in U.S.
maybe an academic, like maybe kind of an academic
institution love to see data. But if we ask,
like, non-profits on the ground who are doing
aid work, would they see randomized trials
and sort of building counterfactuals as a
sort of non-immediate achievement of their
goals? And sort of using resources maybe for
an academic exercise where they could have
been used for direct impact [inaudible]
>>Dean Karlan: Right. So, let me separate
your question into two parts. There's ... there's
a question ... there's an ethics question
-- which I think about a lot -- which is "Should
we be doing evaluation? Should we be doing
research on something?" Right? If there's
an organization and we know it's doing well,
should we be doing any research on them, or
should they be taking all of their available
resources and doing more? And that's not a
question about randomized trials or other
research. That's just a question about should
they be doing research? Are there questions
that they need answers to that we're actually
informing them on? Or, you know, or if they
already have the answers, then why are we
wasting our time and their money? And that's
an ethics issue. But that's a question about,
about of just research. It's not about randomized
trials or not. Now, there's a second issue
which is randomized trials does -- not all
-- There are many situations in which we can
do randomized trials and we basically leave
the organization alone. And they, they really
change very little about what they have to
do, that is intrusive. But, by all means,
there are some times where it is intrusive
to what they're doing. And then, then the
organization has to ask themselves, "Well,
you know, if I'm using the evaluation to make
forward-looking decisions, like, what are
those forward-looking decisions? How important
are they? How much future resources are at
stake here that we make sure we get it right?"
The minute evaluation is used to look forward
rather than to look back, it becomes a much
more appetizing process. Because we realize
it's not about saying are these million dollars
being spent well? But it's saying, "We're
about to spend a hundred more million dollars
in the next 20 years, and how should we best
spend that money?" And the minute that's the
right mindset it becomes a very exciting process
for everybody because they start realizing
the incredible power that the research can
have in helping them maximize their impact.
The other thing to note is that there are
many situations we deal with where the for-profit
firm -- or a non-profit firm could behave
exactly like a for-profit. There are lots
of for-profits -- as you all know here at
Google -- that run randomized trials all the
time. They just don't post, share the data
with dorky academics like me that go write
papers. So there's a lot of situations where
the non-profit could behave exactly like the,
like the for-profit, running internal randomized
trials to help improve their operations. And,
and then the partnership with academia in
some of those situations is a little bit of
a quid pro quo called "it's like we're giving
free consulting advice in exchange for data.
They're agreeing to let their results be made
public in exchange for the free consulting
advice." And so there's a, that often does,
we do, I have been involved in exchanges that
are more or less of that nature. [pointing
to audience] Yeah?
>>Male Audience Member #2: Hi. Thanks for
coming to talk to us. I was wondering if there
was a mechanism that you had thought of that
in terms of that one philosophical problem
that you posed earlier about child drowning
in the lake. I think often, or at least one
major reason people might think of is, "Well,
someone else is going to save them." Is there
kind -- I mean, have you kind of explored
that mechanism of social versus individual
responsibility, and, you know, how that kind
of all ties together? And you know, you came
up with a lot of kind of like opportunity
costs type individual responsibility scenarios.
But, you know, is there one that kind of captures
this ... this kind of problem I said?
>>Dean Karlan: So. I mean, I totally agree
that, I mean, I've definitely --. That is
a common reaction to that, and there's a couple
... So I have two thoughts for you. One is
I'm gonna change the analogy on you in order
to still make the opportunity cost fine. So,
fine. There's three other people standing
by the side of the lake. Are you not going
to jump? Are you really gonna just walk away
because there's three other people not jumping
in, either? Right?
>>Male Audience Member #2: [inaudible]
>>Dean Karlan: So, but there's an element
there where there's now I've made it both
the same. And the point is there are many
situations in, in developing countries where
the equilibrium is what it is. And the situation
right now is very simple. $300 can save a
child's life. Right? And so the fact that
there's a billion people out there that could
also send $300 is neither here nor there.
The equilibrium right now is, is what it is.
And on the margin, you're making a trade-off.
Now, you know, like I said, my other favorite
way of dealing with it is, you know, put a
mob of people on the side of the lake and,
and ask whether the ethical thing is to just
stand there even if nobody else is moving.
And most people would say no, you know. You
might look around a little and hope someone
else goes in first. But at the end of the
day, are you really just not going to go?
Now, I think the other, the other take-away
I have from your, from your question when
I think about this is, is, is what it tells
us about how we, how we can be motivating
giving. So I go back to the, to the website
app that I want to see created. And I think
there's a lot of lessons to learn from that
exact question you posed about ways to make
that app better; ways to incorporate a social
dimension to it so that people don't feel
like they can free-ride and they really make
it salient that, "No, your action and your
action alone can do this. And others aren't
going to do it, and you can't just rely on
others." And I think that, that kind of question
you posed is something that gives me an idea.
You know, there's specific things within that
app that one might want to test in order to
figure that out more. [pointing to audience]
Yeah?
>>Male Audience Member #3: Hi. I ... As a
small-time donor, I think that it's really
great to be able to feel like the dollars
I'm putting in are doing good. And so I was
really excited when I discovered Give Well.
And I was wondering if you know of other organizations
like that that are helping to ... I guess,
take your academic work and make it more accessible
to people like me?
>>Dean Karlan: Right. No, and so ... There's
one domestically which I'm, I'm familiar with
but not as well as, not as much as Give Well
called Root Cause. There's -- Guide Star is,
is, is changing its -- it's gonna be new soon.
We actually just met with some people yesterday.
And they are trying to, trying to incorporate
information from groups like Give Well, Guide
Star. I'm sorry, Give Well, Root Cause, Innovations
for Poverty Action and, and figure out how
to get that out to people. I think the -- you
know, the challenge is that, you know, as
a donor you want to be ... There's a very
simple formula that you're trying to solve.
You're trying to maximize A times B. A is:
Does the idea work? Does the idea of what
the program is doing ... Is it the right idea
in that place and that context? And B is:
Do they do what they say they're going to
do? So, you know, they say they're doing bed
nets and that's great. But, you know, you
sent $1000 or $10,000. How many bed nets actually
got into the hands of individuals? Right.
And what you want to do as a donor is multiply
those two together and maximize it. A zero
in either and you're out of luck. Right? Now
the book and our work is very focused on that
first. There is some of work that we're now
starting to do about the second to try to
understand more about transparency and governance
of NGOs. But it's, it's much further back.
One of the nice things about groups like Give
Well is they're trying to tackle both at the
same time. The other way of dealing with it
is to think about projects. And this is why
we started the Proven Impact Fund that Jake
mentioned. And this is saying, "Well, the
organizational assessment is a, is a tricky
beast." What's much easier to say is, "This
organization in that particular location we
know is doing a particular project and we
know what they are doing. And so let's go
fund that project." And that's an easier beast
to, to think through and to, to analyze than
an entire organization where you don't know
-- OK, I know this organization's one project
in Ethiopia is good, but they have 17 other
programs. Can I assume that there's an overall
organizational effectiveness or not? And so,
you know, the two approaches ... and I'm not
sure which is the right one in the long run.
I can just tell you that we're taking -- with
the Proven Impact Fund -- the project approach
of saying, "Is the idea proven? And then,
here are some projects we know that are doing
this." I do like the other two. I think the
world is good with both. [pause]
>>Eric: Well, we've come to the end of our
time. Everyone, please join me in thanking
Dean and Jacob for coming. [applause]
>>Dean Karlan: Come on up. Thank you, everyone.
It was great to be here.